we got this from Daily Mail take a look
at this Google drops its sponsorship of
Pride and drag show after hundreds of
workers signed a petition calling it a
direct affront to the religious beliefs
and sensitivities of Christians
what is this Sheamus
I thought you guys were being oppressed
you thought it was a war on Christian
listen we're pushing back we're saying
we're done we're finished no I mean
obviously this isn't Christians are one
of the the groups that you're allowed to
hate on in America and as it turns out
they're getting kind of sick of it and
they're starting to actually stand up
for their valleys it's a beautiful thing
to see and I'm very proud of all of
these people for standing up and saying
something because one thing we've said
on the show countless times is that if
you're in one of these positions if
you're at one of these companies and
you're too afraid to speak up the
problem is only going to get worse so
thank you to everyone who signed this
and but I also think we're finally
starting to see conservatives take the
advice that for one I've been saying for
a long time and that's use their own
laws against them it is illegal to
discriminate on the basis of gender sex
race religion national origin Etc so
when they announce they're doing this
this is what I was saying about that kid
the kid in Boston or whatever who wore
the shirt that said there are two
genders and they're like you gotta take
off the shirt it offends people
they should have immediately said okay
we are counter suing for the school to
remove anything referencing Pride
because it offends Christians yeah and
now we're seeing it these Google
employees were like hey you're
discriminating against the space on
religion that's illegal and they what do
Google do I don't think Google cares
about Christians I think they're worried
about lawsuits yeah they'll lose them
dude it'll be like Easter and then their
little Google graphic will be some
insanely obscure Marxist theorists
birthday or something I mean they don't
care about Christians at all yeah oh I
agree with you on that but I think a lot
of these companies are starting to wake
up I think the Bud Light boycott was
incredibly successful the outrage On
Target uh and another exciting thing is
that uh conservatives are not just able
you know we're not just boycotting these
companies now they're taking their
dollars and shopping with their values
and you're seeing marketplaces you had
Michael Seifert on last night from
Public Square the dude's crushing it
he's got like a million daily or monthly
active users tens of thousands of
businesses from all across the country
on his app Public Square and uh you know
Americans are like I don't want to give
my dollars to these companies that hate
my guts I want to shop with my values
I'm going to support a local business in
my community that says they're you know
respect me and respect my values and so
uh it's a good step in the right
direction but like
I agree with what Sheamus is saying you
go on to Google on Easter and there's
nothing but if you go on to Google on
Juneteenth it's the biggest celebration
in the history of the world so yeah or
or it could be like a Christian holiday
and they'll find a way to honor
something else instead it's just it's
ridiculous I want to know more about
this story uh what did Google actually
pull support from they were going to
have a drag show they say Google dropped
its sponsorship of a San Francisco Pride
event the tech giant sponsored a series
of LGBT events across the us annually
and this year the headline event was due
to be a pride and drag show at Beau gay
bar featuring popular performer peaches
Christ
but employees noticed Google removed the
show from its internal events page after
a petition was launched opposing the
event on religious grounds well it
sounds like they did it because the guy
the performer named himself Christ yeah
they're like directly and clearly
mocking Christianity
file a federal lawsuit over the sisters
of Perpetual Indulgence performing at uh
Dodgers yep and it's like if you want to
do a drag show fine you probably
shouldn't have kids there and it
shouldn't be done in the stadium but you
want to bring on people to explicitly
mock someone a group of people sorry
those are your laws you can't do that
Sue I suppose a drag show doesn't
necessarily upset Christianity but it's
calling yourself Christ that upset
Christianity well drag shows upset
Christians too but I think in order to
put together an open letter that says
there's religious discrimination
specifically it obviously helps that
it's an open mockery of Christianity
yeah drag shows probably bother
Christians for a lot of reasons but not
as Christians and they don't necessarily
well even even as Christians right like
the Deuteronomy says a man is not
supposed to wear a woman's clothing or
what man's clothing right I understand
that but my point is
if a guy puts out a dress and crazy
makeup and ends on stage he's not
intentionally trying to attack
Christians yeah no that's what I'm
saying I mean the fact that they this
guy was specifically singling
Christianity out gives them the grounds
to say it's religious discrimination if
the con if the company we work at funds
this or sponsors this
I was thinking about Shakespeare a lot
lately because they used to wear drag
the women weren't allowed to perform
weren't allowed to be actors back then
so they would it would all be all the
women would be played by men in drag but
it was widely accepted I don't know how
how grotesque they would get on stage
this is there's a lot of simulated sex
this is culture War winning
this is Google of all organizations
backing off of a pride event and it's
not the first time we've seen something
like this Sheamus actually put out a
cartoon uh today that it's been a very
bad pride month exactly they haven't
been getting what they've wanted
Starbucks pulled back right yeah and
then James cartoon the woman looks at
her phone and all the all the logos are
changing back to normal but yeah after
like a day or two these companies are
are pulling away from this because
regular people are saying not interested
I didn't see all the companies change
their logos from their normal logo to
their pride logo this this year are you
changing your picture for Maga month I
will be of course yeah I mean everyone
on July 1st everyone's profile pictures
have to be changed to an American flag
version but Sally use your blue check
for a little while on Twitter if you
change your picture yep what yeah
careful I've heard that too or your name
yeah
change your profile picture to be the
same one but with a background of an
American flag you still lose yes change
your profile picture it takes about
three days really get it reverified it
took me about three days yeah you still
get it back but but
what do you love more that check mark or
your flag
I got no questions
who needs a check mark when you got an
America yeah but we're we're corporate
verified so I think we don't that
wouldn't matter for us they might Fast
Track you because we're we're we're at
an approved organization with Twitter
you know what I'm gonna do it anyway
yeah I believe you're right though Alex
that it is a policy that if you change
your name on Twitter or your profile
picture there's a day or there's a
there's a set amount of time where
they've got to re-verify you and then
they don't charge you money or anything
they just need to make a way it works
for organizations
we just give someone verification and
you're verified instantly well did you
see Congressman Wesley hunt and you just
had him on the program he's introducing
a resolution uh in Congress to make July
American Pride month and so Omega month
American Pride month maybe get the idea
from your show but uh you know it's
going to be a congressional resolution
and so if anybody disrespects the law
well gonna hold him accountable June is
American greatness month and so what was
happening was all of these organizations
were changing their corporate logos to
rainbows to symbolize uh God's covenant
to the Earth so it was actually you know
they're they're all Christians it's just
a long game it's a long game no but you
know I was saying this uh for a while I
think Sheamus I think you should fly a
rainbow flag and I think Christians
should March their protests with rainbow
Flags
out you need to make it abundantly clear
this is ours you took it from us you
make I would recommend that you take the
actual Rainbow the full colors uh in
God's covenant and fly that flag so it
is somewhat discernably different but
kind of similar the point being do you
really think the left
based on how they operate tribally is
going to defend their use of it they're
gonna they're gonna run screaming oh the
left the left's gonna claim that
Christians appropriated the rainbow from
the lgbtq community they'll stop Flying
the rainbow flag they'll change you
think so absolutely you'll be like we're
totally you you'll respond to them hey
that's really cool that you have a
rainbow that's our symbol and it's been
for thousands of years too stole it but
don't even say that just be like we're
gonna fly this we're gonna fly a rainbow
flag too then when they go in March all
you got to do is when you see a guy with
a pride flag be like hey Christians look
no no no we're not they're like it's
Christoph fascists they're trying to
take the country over and force their
values on like if if you're not
Christians why are you flying God's
covenant flag but it's not the pride
flag it'll be like that's one of the
deadly sins that does it that is
Covenant the rainbow's the symbol of
God's covenant it's a Christian symbol
and has been forever yeah so oh it's are
there seven colors of the rainbow is
that right yeah I think Seven Virtues in
Catholicism
uh yeah virtues Seven Virtues seven
colors this to the seven deadly sons
of the seven deadly sins yeah there's
seven sins and Seven Virtues each one
has a like like Chastity and lust are
like opposite so they're just seven
Heavenly I would like to get a prism and
uh blast some light behind me and split
it into seven colors behind me I'm not I
don't want to actually fly a flag behind
me but I'd love to get that rainbow
Visage behind me that'd look cool I just
understand why Christians have given up
on that symbol well you know I think I
think because Christians weren't flying
rainbow Flags around before the alphabet
people took it but but still I mean it's
crazy it's crazy to think that for
thousands of years the rainbow was it
was a symbol of Christianity and then 20
30 years ago yeah 50 years ago really
but you know popularized in the past
couple decades all of a sudden now the
rainbow is a symbol of of Pride how did
it become a symbol of Christianity well
because after the the flood God sent a
rainbow as a sign that he would not
flood the world again okay yeah so it's
like the sign of the end of the storm
just in general the storm is the way of
putting it that's I guess that's the way
it's like a promise specifically in this
instance like a promise that he would
not flood the world again like God's
covenant with the Earth but a lot of
people are upset about that yeah about
what the fact that they stole it or that
it won't flood it again because I get it
yeah
a lot of people are like well you know
who am I to question but it's like bro I
will build the boat just let me know
at the the subreddit Noah get the boat
and it just it shows people doing
horrifying things dude watch any random
like
I don't know World Star Hip-Hop video
out of New York late at night and you'll
just be like it's time to build the ark
is it raining yeah yeah I think we're
passing through the torrid meteor storm
stream again what is it every 23 000
years I don't want to miss miscalculate
things but apparently apparently the
last time the Earth was flooded was when
we were passing through the torrid
meteor stream they call it the torrid
because it's when we are viewing Taurus
the constellation is when they when
we're passing through the meteor stream
and those are the meteors that peppered
the North American ice shelf and uh the
north Asian ice shelter yeah Global
flood and apparently we're going to be
passing through this again or are
passing through it right now December
it's amazing this Confluence of events
how things are coming full circle you
may say it peaks in November so it's
better to have your boat built by then
oh boy yeah let's pray that we don't
strike one of these because it's it's
Madness and Chaos out there but there
isn't a magnetic field you know there's
a repulsive mechanism that Earth has I
think that is is working Synergy with us
as long as we don't see the planet off
and I'm not I'm not like a climate
change actor yeah I was gonna say a
whole lot of seconds
it's not the Earth though because
there's a way if we if we knock out our
magnetic field with pollution or
something yeah or like nuclear weapons
we very much it might get hit by uh
outer forces I thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time